sourdough bread with crushed avocado
we think of the flavor and the texture
of avocado rich phenomenal I wanna make
it a bit more vibrant black sesame seeds
a nice pinch of chili flakes I quite
like it hot
touch a salt a touch of pepper so that
nice dry combination of the lemon zest
black sesame seeds the heat your chili
this is light healthy quick what's so
tasty sourdough bread three nice chunky
thick slices open them up highly
seasoned them little touch of olive oil
brings the whole crust to life rubble
left seasoning in but you can use to
better you can use a baguette but the
richness from asado with a silky
creaminess of the avocado is mine brain
and then get the grill up to temperature
and push these down go the extra mile
we've all put bread in a toaster of a
difference grilling the bread this way
is extraordinary that nice smoky
charcoal flavor offer the gas beautiful
now they have Accardo got to treat them
with love respect press on the end here
and your thumb softens you can tell that
avocado is ripe never press here you
just end up bruising it slice down to
fill that stone in the middle and then
just roll around and then it's just a
little gentle twist off stone
and out cut them into quarters the back
of your knife peel back that skin if the
other color is nice and ripe it should
just all fall away slice just take your
quarters and them out and push them into
the bread the riper the avocado the
better the flavor but look for ones free
from soft spots and blemishes which can
suggest bruising get your lemon squeeze
that will stop the avocado from
discoloring and then you get your crunch
ready to go on top sprinkle a very
generous light way for the fragrance
from the lemon zest the crunch from the
sesame seeds the heat that little chili
flake which just wakes up at avocado
they look expensive that for me is a
delicious light start to the day
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
[Music]